plus qu il voit un compte-rendu en vrai
concurrent en tout cas moi je ma poule
ou lajan de coqs paquet il ya rs boukari
qu'on va parler de ton truc car ils sont
va pas parler que d'octogone ce soir non
mais non ça c'était une invention
[Rires]
merci je suis quoi que ce soit la
tchèque je suis pote avec booba - sexe
tombeur a new way c'est vrai rival et on
saute on espère bien mais moi ça leur
met parle quand même d'un mec talent
mais en vacances berthod c'est fini les
vacances pour toi c'est pourquoi je sais
alors franchement sexy terme à sa crosse
alors quand je vais la montrer à booba
[Rires]
rcl est belle je te dirai 31 à moi si tu
devais monter assez caris alors on veut
savoir où on en est ou de cette affaire
déjà tu vas nous expliquer de tous bien
puisque apparemment tu étais lui falloir
déjà faire ce qui tombe bien cette
histoire
non nous moi je sais pas d'incitation à
la violence et moi j'ai qu'une envie
c'est parce que voilà je peux me j'adore
booba lui et droit doit franchement
qu'il faut aussi merci c'est gentil et
moi j'ai juste envie de vous réconcilier
puisque je suis le rabibochage tard non
mais c'est vrai que je suis de
rabibochage est ce qu'il ya une chance
pour que vous réconcilier ou pas alors
que c'est la première phrase la première
prise de parole de booba en tribunes
sincérité la hache de guerre est
enterrée a le charisme d'accord donc ça
ça te fait plaisir
non seulement elle m'a fait plaisir
vraiment tu devrais te poser la question
sur le fait de dire on va enterrer la
hache de guerre avait justement lui il y
en a dix là où il ya un problème en fait
ouais mais lui a dit tu as des bancs
publics sont justement lui l'année qui
voulaient enterrer la hache de guerre
autour d'un combat à la sécheresse a dit
à la juge le combat là je dirais tempéré
oui et c'est vrai que voilà je me suis
dit au lieu qu'ils se tapent devant tout
le monde dans un aéroport ou quand il
croisés ou que ça fasse encore des mecs
qui vont être qu'ils vont être choqués
des légendes avec des enfants à côté
tout ça peut-être c'est mieux
d'organiser un truc voilà un combat de
boxe
moi je pense que c'est une la boxe
anglaise parce que sinon ça va être
n'importe quoi avec des vraies règles
un vrai arbitre ou bien vous organiser
un truc sur un ring et vous faites juste
un petit bisou et vous repartez chacun
de votre côté
ne l'appelez plus bas donc on rappelle
la faire vous n'êtes plus les meilleurs
amis du monde vous étiez copains moment
les deux ou par jamais été son pote j'ai
jamais connue d'accord merci en tout cas
c'est clair ça pardonne vous êtes sûr
que je l'appelle alors je vais l'appeler
d'accord moi c'est ton pote c'est vrai
mais tu ne sais ce qu'ils pensent au
fond de lui puisque c'est ton pote n'y a
pas d'histoire de rabibochage entre lui
et moi c'est bien donc c'est un peu ma
vie de mon côté lui fait sa vie de son
côté message très vite mon côté n'est
pas content c'est buback et sur moi
c'est pas moi donc si tu veux la paix à
peine mais je vais lui dire direct à la
personne qui flippe ici rappelle que
j'appelle que tu vois là à l'eau comment
ça va tu m'entends ça va alors on est
sur le plateau en direct comment ça va
peut être en forme
merci mon chéri du salut tpm p merci
impôts lui dire merci on peut
l'applaudir ma fille alors y'a qu'à
risque est là et carris ça va avec 2,10
à vaccari fra b ou quoi 1 et ça démarre
très bien alors booba tu as dit que tu
veux lui ont tiré dans ton cul frérot
on se calme
s'il vous plaît on n'est pas venu pour
ça on fera tout le cellulaire même temps
à la barre et sans lune et la balle à
l'intérieur
non booba booba booba dit qu'ils
voulaient enterrer la hache de guerre
elle n'a pas inventé un jeu de guerre
c'est des histoires tout ça attendez
deux minutes parce que lui et vous
l'enterrez la hache de guerre et leurs
parents perrache d'âge de guerre même si
un contrat même si un combat sera pas
enterré nous c'est très bien alors
d'autres
ou alors il aurait entendu que je t'ai
dit alors tu en penses quoi
laissez-le répondent booba bon alors
appareil arrive est inquiète
apparemment je te le dis booba charisme
ne veut pas combattre voilà ils te
disent ah non mais moi je lui ai dit je
suis chaud comme jamais oui mais oui
mais non mais on veut pas de bas il faut
pas se battre c'est lui qui a inventé
cette histoire scénarii et le faux pas
ce soit nous on aime bien l'idée d'un
contrat non il est là au téléphone on
rigole quand deux heures on a bien
rigolé ravin non sérieux bas dans la rue
n'en veut plus de combats dans la rue
l'argent accordé le combat dans la rue
allent à orly c'est lui qui a commencé
c'est lui qui est venu avec ses potes
non mais juste non mais oui mais
justement on ne veut plus de ça même
booba il faut plus de ça alors il veut
plus a donc il veut se battre sur un
ring de mitonner d'un truc chez les 10
ans des souris fois je crois que c'était
une mauvaise idée
ça n'allait pas malgré pas mal bu
neopost reste à réparer alors je te le
dis voilà lui
booba ils voulaient enterrer la hache de
guerre il voulait plus se battre dans la
rue comme ça il a dû enfin un vrai
combat de boxe
voilà relégué avec cet oeil à pâte à
choux le temps passer ah bon alors je
vais devoir que toi aussi
en fait ce qu'il veut en contre en tout
cas moi ce que j'aime la foule
jan de cock s'inquiète il ya rs moi ça
mais on n'attend pas bien bon bah donc
vous bâti nous un truc pas envie de
l'entendre si elle tient bon écoutez en
tout cas je ne sais pas il en est où
cette affaire franchement non mais ce
combat nous ce qu'on veut c'est un
combat dans les règles avec les règles
de boxe mine de rien ces valeurs et de
la boxe et mai car aig cédera bourse aux
oiseaux battu le pen alors il y dix mois
sur un artiste
maintenant s'il veut se battre contre
moi ça va être un combat de rue c'est ce
que je voudrais lui dire dans un même
serveur danza voilà donc qui apparemment
il y aura pas donc de combat de monde
lui mon pote chez moi je suis déçu quand
la salle alors y avait combien de
caméras quand et à la salle et avait des
maquilleuses tout sa grand mère tu fais
du cinéma ont ralenti dans la salle de
sport et ce qu'il a dit il y avait pas
grand mère
la musique ou pas en tout cas j'attends
je veux répondre à ça tombe on n'en a
jamais eu l'habitude va comme ça j'ai
carole rousseau derrière la raison
d'insultés des grands mères c'est
vraiment quelqu'un d'intelligent
mais est ce que oui il était là c'est ça
la question je me pose est ce qu il
prenant le bret qui tu sais booba les
beaux boubous tout cas je voulais faire
la cour à bisous et je voulais faire un
gros bisou au thème est basé cherche toi
et on on brosse bâle iii et merci à tous
et allez ça suffit ça suffit on la
brasse vous bac est parti voilà